Lazy, entitled, stupid,
selfish, dumb, crazy, lost, ignorant,
spoiled, bad, sensitive,
snowflake, annoying,
fucked, and on and on and on.
That's how Millennial and Gen Z-ers
say they're routinely described,
according to SUNY
psychologist Karla Vermeulen,
author of the new book
"Generation Disaster:
Coming of Age Post 9-11."
Who can blame them for being pissed off?
One of the quotes that I
use was someone saying,
"I feel like our generation
has been handed a bill
"for a party we didn't get to attend."
So this is really one of
the main sources of anger
at older generations, at
Boomers in particular.
Younger Americans have
been raised to believe
that their leaders lie about everything,
that the entire financial system existed
to bail out big banks when
they crashed the economy,
that endless war is the
natural state of things,
and that they were about to
be blown up by terrorists
or shot during school at any moment.
I have a chapter in the book
called Lockdown Drills in Kindergarten.
They literally have had these drills
the same way that we had fire drills.
Vermeulen's book looks specifically
at people born between 1990 and 2001,
but her conclusions are broadly relevant
to folks under 40 or so.
She says their fears are mostly overhyped.
Our focus on statistically rare events
such as school shootings have
jacked depression, anxiety,
and resentment through the roof.
The psychological effect of
participating in these drills
for young kids and kids
writing wills to their parents
and thinking they're literally gonna die.
And it's security theater,
the disproportionate attention
and resources that go
towards preventing these
highly, highly unlikely events
relative to the more direct
mental health stressors
kids are actually dealing with.
But the biggest driver
of Generation Disaster's stress
and anger, says Vermeulen,
are narratives about how climate change
is about to destroy the planet
in the very near future.
The world is gonna end in 12 years
if we don't address climate change.
Whether or not you think
that is exaggerated,
this is the messaging that
they've been receiving
and this is definitely the biggest source
of anxiety for them.
I would say school shootings
are kind of the most
acute stressor for them,
but their worries about climate change
and the future of the planet
is truly existential for them.
They talk about not thinking
that they won't be able to have children
or they don't want to have children
because they don't want
to leave them this planet
that they've inherited.
I think that what makes it
so hard for them to deal with
is they feel like there's so
little they can do about it.
Baby Boomers, who hated their own parents
and used to shout slogans like
don't trust anyone over 30,
should be able to empathize
with how Millennials and
Gen Z-ers are feeling.
We need to find ways
of talking more productively
across generation.
Vermeulen says that the essential
starting point is respect.
To the parents, I guess I would
say really listen to them.
A lot of them are delightful.
They are creative.
They are thoughtful.
They are far more sophisticated
than I was at their age
because they've had all of this access
to all of these resources,
everything that they now have
literally in their hand
at their fingertips.
And take their concerns seriously
because they are valid in many ways.
I'll add to that.
We need to have more
fact-based discussions
that take into account vast amounts
of huge social, economic,
and environmental progress
that we either take for granted
or politicians and the press ignore
because it doesn't fit their agenda.
Extreme poverty has
been cut from 94% to 10%
over the past two centuries,
education and literacy have skyrocketed,
racism, sexism, and
homophobia have all declined,
global life expectancy
continues to increase
and democracy is on the rise.
The 2018 UN Climate Report
that supposedly claimed
that the world is going to end in 12 years
actually says nothing of the sort.
Policy analysts such as Scott
Winship note that 70 percent
of American 30-year-olds are doing better
than their parents were at the same age.
For Generation Disaster,
why are their parents
or their grandparents having
these negative reactions?
Beause you don't understand them
any more than they understand you,
but you could probably try that.
Every generation fights
for its place in the world
and there's no question
that the same Boomers
who once sang along to Bob Dylan's
"The Times They Are a-Changin'"
are incredibly slow to exit the stage
and give anyone else a
turn in the spotlight.
There's no question that
Millennials and Gen Z
are facing unique problems
that they didn't cause,
but that's also been true
of every other generation.
We've just lost the ability
to talk to each other
and to listen to views,
not lost entirely, but it is challenging,
listen to views that are
in conflict with our own
and try to understand why
people have these perspectives.